[Música]
gran expectativa en Nueva York donde ya
se encuentra el expresidente
estadounidense Donald Trump para
comparecer el martes ante el gran Jurado
por el caso de presuntos pagos ilegales
a la actriz estadounidense hay tensión
por posibles protestas masivas de Los
Seguidores del ex jefe de estado
el gobernador del estado estadounidense
de Florida roundés firmó la ley que
permite portar armas sin permiso Estatal
la medida en vigorda es el primero de
julio y con ella quienes por tener armas
no necesitarán capacitación especial ni
verificación de antecedentes
México anunció la muerte de otro de los
migrantes que estuvieron en el incendio
del centro de detención de Ciudad Juárez
lo que elevó el total de fallecidos a 40
a la vez se conocen nuevos testimonios
de supervivientes que revelan el pánico
vivido en el interior del lugar
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos porque hay expectativa y
tensión en la ciudad de Nueva York donde
ya se encuentra el expresidente Donald
Trump quien Este martes tendrá que
presentarse ante una corte de Manhattan
por el caso de los presuntos pagos
ilegales a la actriz pornográfica stormy
Daniels las autoridades se preparan para
posibles masivas protestas de Los
Seguidores del ex mandatario el fiscal
del distrito anunció que dará una
conferencia de prensa luego de la
audiencia Rodrigo cedano tiene los
detalles
Se abrieron las puertas de mar halago y
salió la comitiva de seguridad de Donald
Trump en el camino al aeropuerto de Palm
Beach en torno a 200 simpatizantes del
ex presidente y rumbo a Nueva York
en donde más prensa que simpatizantes lo
esperaron frente a la torre trampa
apoyamos a este hombre amamos al
presidente Trump el verdadero presidente
Trump deberá compadecer el martes ante
un juzgado por los presuntos pagos a la
actriz porno stormy Daniels durante la
campaña de 2016 con ello se habría
buscado el silencio de Daniels por una
relación extramatrimonial 10 años antes
un juez que le dirá Cuáles son los
cargos en su contra le preguntará Cómo
se declarará Y en este caso no habrá
fianza Entonces liberará al expresidente
Bajo su propia responsabilidad
también se le tomarán sus huellas una
caza de brujas según sus seguidores
está siendo perseguido políticamente En
mi opinión porque Alvin bracke nunca
acusa a los verdaderos criminales la
acusación sin embargo no es por el acto
de pagar por silencio algo que no está
tipificado como delito la vendría de un
presunto registro ilegal de Los 130.000
dólares pagados como un reembolso a su
abogado Michael cohen
like
Parece que habrá al menos algún fraude
financiero de campaña y que elevaría el
caso de un delito menor a un delito
grave y eso es relativamente grave pero
es la clase de delito grave más baja en
el estado de Nueva York
por el momento la gran manzana refuerza
la seguridad ante un evento tan
relevante para el futuro político del
país se esperan manifestaciones de los
simpatizantes de Trump quien ve como su
popularidad vuelva a aumentar por este
caso el gobernador del estado
estadounidense de Florida el republicano
ron de santis firmó la polémica ley que
permite aportar armas de fuego sin
necesidad de permiso Estatal la
normativa entra en vigor el próximo
primero de julio permite que las
personas que lleven armas ocultas en
público no requieran capacitación
especial ni verificación de antecedentes
la iniciativa ha generado un fuerte
rechazo entre los demócratas y
organizaciones sociales que recuerdan
los tiroteos masivos de la discoteca
paulsa de Orlando en 2016 con 49
víctimas mortales y el de la escuela
secundaria Marjorie stonemann Douglas en
parkland en 2018 con 17 muertos
este lunes la secretaría de seguridad de
México informó de la muerte de uno de
los heridos tras el incendio en un
centro de detención migrante en Ciudad
Juárez por lo que los decesos
ascendieron a 40 testimonios de los
sobrevivientes continúan revelando los
detalles de la angustia Que se vivió en
el transcurso de las llamas Rafael Pérez
nos cuenta más
una tragedia que sigue cobrando vidas
este lunes la secretaría de seguridad de
México informó de una nueva muerte a
causa del incendio en un puesto de
detención migrante de Ciudad Juárez con
el fallecimiento Hacienda 40 el número
de víctimas de los sobrevivientes 23 se
encuentran hospitalizados el migrante
venezolano Edward Caraballo cuenta lo
que vivió durante la conflagración Duré
casi 20 minutos encerrado ahí a poder 5
minutos Llamando a mi familia para así
me contestaba Hasta qué día no
obviamente para el baño me metí para el
baño me rompí la cara con mi suéter
Edward se encuentra en Estados Unidos
recibiendo tratamiento médico por
sobreexposición al humo la imagen de su
esposa mientras él luchaba por su vida
dio la vuelta al mundo
y mi esposa me cuenta que la masa me
parece Pero ahí no sentía nada trataba
débil y pues se gritaba lloraba y hoy
gritaba también llorando pero yo no
entendía porque estaba en otro lado pues
la compañera de Edward vinagre Infante
también se encuentra en territorio
estadounidense juntos deben presentarse
ahora ante la autoridad fronteriza hasta
el momento las autoridades mexicanas Han
detenido a cinco personas por los hechos
en otras noticias la presidenta de bueno
continuó su visita por Centroamérica en
Belice donde agradeció por lo que
aseguró es un respaldo a su democracia
Belice junto a Guatemala Son los únicos
dos países de Centroamérica que
mantienen lazos diplomáticos con la isla
y no con china Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
corresponsal de France 24 nos amplió la
información
la presidenta de Taiwán concluye este
lunes una visita oficial por
Centroamérica con un día ajetreado en
Belice en donde asistió a la cita más
importante que era la presentación de su
discurso frente a la asamblea nacional
de Belmopán en sus declaraciones la
mandataria sáez subrayó que el pueblo de
Taiwán enfrenta una amenaza constante
por parte de su vecino frente al
estrecho de Taiwán en Clara referencia a
la china que lideran una china que
acumula provocaciones sobre todo con el
anuncio de hoy de la reunión oficial que
sostendrá la presidentai con el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes de los Estados Unidos
Kevin mccarthy y con otros miembros del
Congreso programada para este miércoles
5 de abril esto en la escala que hará la
mandataria y su delegación en California
luego del viaje por Centroamérica y de
regreso a la isla de Taiwán por su parte
el Primer Ministro John briceño reiteró
el reconocimiento a Taiwán como un
estado el verano le agradeció por la
inversión económica sobre todo por una
subvención de más de 16 millones de
dólares para la construcción de un
hospital en el Callo de uno de los
puntos turísticos más importantes de
Belice donde no hay atención
hospitalaria Y esto es un caso
particular porque justamente la
presidentai viene de visitar aquí en
Guatemala el hospital de Chimaltenango
cuya construcción se logró por la
inversión taiwanesa de más de 22
millones de dólares pero que ahora está
envuelto en un caso de corrupción por el
cual el viceministro de salud está
encarcelado Fue capturado el
viceministro de salud del gobierno de
Alejandro yamatei Costa Rica ha sido
históricamente uno de los países más
seguros de América Latina pero en los
últimos tiempos se ha convertido en un
punto de almacenamiento y transbordo
para el narcotráfico por lo que han
surgido bandas criminales que llevaron a
registrar un récord de homicidios en
es el país de la pura vida y es conocido
por haber sido uno de los más seguros de
América Latina sin embargo la
inseguridad aumenta en Costa Rica una
bala perdida mató en febrero a Samuel
Arroyo de ocho años esto provocó la
indignación Popular
podríamos andar tranquilos hasta ciertas
horas pero ya eso es diferente ha
aumentado mucho la violencia los asaltos
sin importarles que una bala puede herir
a un inocente en 2022 Costa Rica
registró su récord de homicidios con 657
están surgiendo bandas criminales
locales formadas por gente muy joven el
país ha pasado de ser un lugar de paso
para el narcotráfico hacer un punto de
almacenamiento y transbordo de drogas
hacia Europa de eso de comienzos son en
su mayoría a miembros de estructuras
criminales a gatilleros o sicarios o a
personas que tienen algún rol importante
dentro de esas estructuras
ante la búsqueda de soluciones el
ministro de seguridad ha elogiado el
método bukele Mientras que el canciller
fue más cauto en palabras a France 24
durante la Cumbre iberoamericana
nosotros no tenemos un estado de
excepción como en El Salvador Aunque sí
reconocemos que se han incrementado
algunos puntos de inseguridad en el país
sobre todo el asesinato entre bandas de
narcotraficantes es un punto focal que
merece nuestra atención y estamos
haciendo todo esfuerzo para combatirlas
dentro del marco del estado de derecha
Costa Rica ha tenido históricamente una
perspectiva de seguridad relajada sin un
ejército permanente pero la situación
podría cambiar
fin del informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]